you were working ColdFusion period
[Music]
hi welcome to another ColdFusion video
as we approach the 2020s it's becoming
clearer that strangely enough our future
may be a battery-powered one today
four billion smartphones depend on
batteries battery powered electric cars
are becoming a reality and even parts of
cities such as Adelaide and entire
islands in Hawaii are being powered by
batteries as I've shown in previous
videos in addition to all of this the
most recent development is the mass
production electric aircraft I've been
spending a little bit of time with one
such aircraft called the Pipistrel alpha
electro and it's been really interesting
flown in it and even taken the controls
for about 30 seconds here's how it
sounds starting up
[Music]
and how it sounds flying past relatively
quiet it's all fascinating stuff and
there'll be a short documentary on my
thoughts on this tack coming up later on
this channel but anyway if the point of
me stating all of that was just to
highlight that there's a growing need
for high-performance batteries in our
world we demand more and whoever can
come up with the technology to push the
state of the art forward will find
themselves in an extremely lucrative
position the race for the perfect
battery technology is on and the latest
contender is Samsung just before we get
started I just want to give a shout out
to Squarespace for helping make this
video possible Squarespace is one of the
easiest ways to build a website there's
nothing to patch or upgrade ever and
it's flexible I personally like how easy
the templates are two years when I was
making my music page I could just drag
and drop SoundCloud links right in if
you want to create your own website
whether you're an artist or blogger or
just have a cool idea that you want to
showcase definitely consider using
Squarespace visit www.hp.com/recycle way
to improve lithium-ion battery
technology with graphene so what is
graphene graphene is a crystalline form
of carbon in which a single layer of
carbon atoms are arranged in a regular
hexagonal pattern think of it like this
imagine a diamond now slice this diamond
so it's only just one atom thick this
slice is still as strong as a diamond
but flexible light and an excellent
conductor of heat and electricity
graphene's material properties are
staggering is the thinnest material
known to man and the strongest ever
measured it can stretch up to 20% of its
length and is the most efficient
electrical conductor known and at room
temperature it can sustain current
densities six orders of magnitude higher
than that of copper it has the best
thermal conductivity of any material and
is the most imporant aerial ever
discovered it's incredible stuff
just as a visual illustration of just
how strange graphene is here is a video
of some carbon nanotubes which are
basically a rolled-up version of
graphene
[Music]
so with that in mind let's take a closer
look at samsung's graphene battery
samson's version of graphene comes in
the form of little balls basically a 3d
structure synthesized from silicon
dioxide
here are some magnified images of the
growth of graphene balls from silicon
dioxide magnified and magnified again
these graphene balls cover the anode and
cathode material this enables the
batteries to charge 5 times faster than
currently possible as well as some other
benefits which we'll talk about in a bit
the new battery technology was developed
by Samsung SDI which is the company's
battery arm and the samsung advanced
institute of technology these two bodies
were in collaboration with the seoul
national university school of chemical
and biological engineering as a side
point samsung SDI had just involved some
new battery tech at the 2018 Detroit
Motor Show that claims that just after
20 minutes of charge they can power an
electric car for 600 kilometers alright
so what are the advantages
these graphene balls when put on the
cathode of the battery suppress the
damaging reactions that occur with
continued charging while also improving
efficiency of current flow the new cells
are said to retain 78.6% of the capacity
after 500 charge cycles this is about on
pile of current batteries but this
should improve with time in the case of
extremely rapid charging things are a
little bit different he is a chart of
the capacity of a regular battery versus
a battery with graphene balls added over
time this isn't the scenario with
extreme charging notice the steep
drop-off of the regular battery which is
the black dotted line normal batteries
in comparison just can't handle the
current samsung also states that these
new batteries could have 45% higher
capacities than when compared to the
current state-of-the-art
charging times will be 12 minutes
instead of one hour a lot of people
might be thinking that this new
technology would be expensive and that's
quite logical but Samsung does claim
that these graphene balls are cheap to
manufacture because it's using a new
method called chemical vapor deposition
quote our research enables mass a
synthesis of multifunctional composite
material graphene at an affordable price
at the same time we were able to
considerably enhance the capabilities of
lithium-ion batteries where markets for
mobile devices and electric vehicles is
growing rapidly our commitment is to
continuously explore and develop
secondary battery technology in light of
these trends in quote it's probably
important to note that this isn't just
some hypotheticals or some conjecture
but rather the results after some
rigorous testing the detailed paper was
published in nature and can be found
online and I'll leave a link to it below
if you're interested in reading more
about the technology so while this is
very exciting stuff Samsung has not yet
stated when they plan to release the
technology and after what happened with
the galaxy note 5 I think they'll be
taking some precautions to make sure
everything is in order before release so
battery at 45% higher capacity and 12
minutes charging time sounds promising
and I think if there's any company that
has the resources to make this happen it
would be Samsung
Appl sure has the money but they don't
seem to be as widespread and dedicated
in their research department so let me
know your thoughts in the comment
section below since we're at the end of
the video I just want to make a quick
announcement I'm actually writing a book
right now and have been for the past six
months it's about the history of science
and technology from the Industrial
Revolution till today you'll be hearing
more about it in the future and I also
have some corresponding videos that I'll
put up on this channel thanks for
watching guys this has been - go go
you've been watching cold fusion feel
free to subscribe if you've just
stumbled across this channel and I'll
catch you again soon for the next video
cheers guys have a good one
[Music]